DRAWING FROM THE SUMMIT IN
SINGAPORE.
WE ARE IN SEOUL TONIGHT.
>> NORTH KOREA CLAIMED THEY
DISMANTLED THEIR NUCLEAR TEST
SITE.
BROUGHT A GROUP TO WATCH THE
EXPLOSION.
I WOULDN'T SAY IT WAS
SPECTACULAR BUT THERE ARE NO
INTERNATIONAL EXPERTS TO CONFIRM
THE CLAIMS.
THEN A FEW HOURS LATER THE
CANCELLATION, FOR NOW AT LEAST,
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP OF THE
PLANNED SUMMIT IN SINGAPORE WITH
KIM JONG-UN.
THE SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID PERPLEXED
BY THE NEWS.
HE SAID DENUCLEARIZATION CAN'T
BE DELAYED OR ABANDONED.
MOON HAS MOVED TO BRING THE
CRISIS TO A DIMLY MAT I CAN
RESOLUTION INCLUDING HIS OWN
SUMMIT LAST MONTH WITH KIM KIM
JONG-UN ON THE PUGH MZ.
>> SOUTH KOREA HAS REACHED OUT
PUBLICLY.
>> REGIONAL OBSERVES ARE HOPING
OUT HOPE.
FOR NOW AT LEAST THEY SAY
>> THIS IS A HUGE BUMP IN THE
ROAD.
I SUPPOSE WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT
TO SEE WHAT THE NORTH KOREAN
REACTION IS AND THE REACTION OF
OTHER PLAYERS AS WELL.
>> IT IS EARLY FRIDAY MORNING
HERE ON THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A REACTION YET
FROM THE NORTH KOREAN GOVERNMENT
TO THE WHITE HOUSE MOVES.
THE REGIME HAS GOTTEN BETTER
WITH THEIR REACTION TIME,
RECENTLY.
THEY MAY WANT TO CONSIDER WHAT
IS NEXT AFTER THIS WHITE HOUSE
DECISION.
BACK TO YOU, BRET.